foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
S Morgan uncensored tonight Donald Trump
returns to center stage on Prime Time
with a fuselada fake news how should we
handle his gigantic fibbing without
gagging a front runner to be president
will debate that with media Titan Jeremy
Bowen
enters the Barefoot of British politics
by slamming the government's immigration
Bill did he overstepped the mark we'll
debate that too
thus California considers paying black
residents up to 1.2 million dollars each
in compensation for historic sins is
that Justice or is it just divisive
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored Donald Trump is right back
where he likes to be his leading cable
news it's generating headlines across
the planet and he's smack bang in the
middle of a storm of his own making and
one that's of course all about him
viewers tuning into CNN's Infamous
already Infamous Town Hall last night
could have been forgiven for thinking it
was a rerun from 2016. this was Trump
the showman shooting from the hip with
insults falsehoods and outrageous
diversions in a friendly audience full
of Republicans that like him met with
laughter and Applause however
inappropriate that may have been firmly
in his crosshairs was e Gene Carroll a
woman that a civil jury had just decided
this week had been sexually abused by
Trump in the 1980s and been defamed by
him as a liar
I never met her I have no idea who she
is I had a picture taken years ago with
her and her husband nice guy John
Johnson he was a newscaster a very nice
man she called him an ape happens to be
African African-American called him an
ape the judge wouldn't allow us to put
that in
her dog or her cat was named vagina
what was textbook Trump wasn't it for
every criticism there was a baseless
insult aimed at somebody else grilled on
hoarding classified documents at
Mar-A-Lago you responded simply by
attacking the hosts from CNN Caitlin
Collins
why you held on to those documents when
you knew the federal government was
seeking them and then had given you a
subpoena to return are you ready are you
ready can I talk yeah what's your answer
can you mind I would like for you to
answer that question okay it's a very
simple day that's why I asked it it's
very simple that you're a nasty person
I'll tell you what
this is how Trump dominated the election
cycle of course when he propelled
himself to that stunning victory in the
first place in 2016. Rosie O'Donnell was
a fat piggy said Hillary Clinton was
crooked and so on and so on everyone was
a loser apart from him Isis will lose it
CNN was sick losers with very bad
ratings billionaire Mike Bloomberg was a
loser who has money but can't debate
Hillary Clinton was the worst ambiguous
loser of all time every time Trump spoke
or tweeted you reshape and use agenda
around himself let's be honest all the
time it was entertaining and sometimes
laugh out loud funny but lots changed
since 2016. it doesn't feel entertaining
or funny anymore there's a lot of murky
water now under the Trump Bridge he
helped Insider riots at the Capitol but
people died last night I said he might
pardon some of the rioters he's been
criminally indicted over hush money to
the porn star Stormy Daniels he's been
proven in a civil court of sexually
abused a magazine writer he couldn't yet
face charges for trying to find votes to
overturn defeat an election which he
still claims is rigged and that's why
this all feels very different than
2015-16
yes Trump is the front runner to be the
Republican nominee yes 74 million people
did vote for him in 2020 yes he could
well be the next president of the United
States again there's also misinformation
machine spewing fake news across the
planet faster than anyone can keep up
with it and if America is going to get
to grits for the second coming of Donald
Trump it's going to have to figure out
how to handle his incessant lies
well joining me now is BBC's
International auditor and host of the
hit new podcast front lines of
Journalism Jeremy Bowen Donald Trump's
former White House communications
director Anthony scaramucci and the Fox
News contributor Liz peek so welcome to
all of you a stellar panel Jeremy let me
start with you you've got this brilliant
podcast series I know it's brilliant
because I'm in it
um and I really enjoyed doing it by the
way you said you were there to be
Hannibal Lecter that's why I was setting
up to be and a very nice meal I had too
uh roast Bowen um what do we do about
children before you answer that I want
to play a clip this is from the podcast
actually it's from a clip from an
interview you did with Basha al-assad
the president of Syria and the reason
it's relevant is that you categorize
this clip as the big lie and you're
interviewing him about his use of barrel
bombs and it's the way that he responds
to you in the interview which is I think
very pertinent to Trump
and you remember doing this interview
let's just listen to this
wouldn't deny that included under the
category of bombs are these Barrel bombs
which are indiscriminate weapons no
there's no indiscriminate weapons it was
a lie a big one there's no variable and
I seized on it grateful people have been
lying surely how how surely why you're
sure I thought his lie was backfiring on
him especially when he tried to turn it
into a joke I haven't heard of army
using barrels or maybe cooking but then
I realized that he had a strategy for
the interview it just wasn't the one I'd
expected large barrels full of
explosives and projectiles which are
dropped from helicopters and explode
with devastating effect there's been a
lot of testimony about these things no
there's no indiscriminate weapons we
don't have bubbles again it's like
talking about cooking pots so we don't
have cooking pots
I mean in a way that sort of chuckle at
the end again that's the kind of trump
way of dealing with these things laugh
it off distract whatever you can do but
interesting that the big lie was then
the big lie we now see with Trump of
course with the denial of losing the
election
how do we handle it as a global media
how do you handle Trump Caitlin Collins
is an incredibly skilled correspondent
but even she got kind of overwhelmed by
the sheer volume of Lies well I think
it's difficult with tram because he's
like a machine he spews the whole thing
out well I was talking to Assad I knew
that I was on very Solid Ground because
I'd actually seen the aftermath of
barrel bomb attacks myself I'd
interviewed the eyewitnesses when the
buildings behind them were still burning
so I knew that they were happening to
start with also I think if you're doing
an interview like that you'll know this
very well you know you wargaming a
little bit you'd think well he might say
this so I'll say this and I'll get ready
for it
but I think what you have to do is stick
to your guns but it's quite difficult
because when politicians are using lies
our leaders using lies as a as a
technique then they often come in layers
there might be an underlying fake
premise underneath it then a lot of
details some of which might have a bit
of Truth in some of which might not so
what I'm doing and I'm thinking to
myself well do I try and go for the
underlying premise do I try and go for
what's on top of that oh I just simply
say you're not telling the truth
you had to rep Trump for how many days
was it 11
well thank you for getting it right you
know she once said 10. I did you hurt my
feelings do you know what I felt what I
felt watching it Anthony last night it
was gripping to watch obviously
everything about Trump in a live
television environment is gripping but I
thought the big strategic error that CNN
made as a network was to have a large
baying crowd of Republican voters most
of whom seemed very big fans of Donald
Trump who would then cheer and laugh in
my opinion a completely inappropriate
moments like when he was attacking the
woman who's just won the sex abuse case
against it
yeah well a couple of quick things
number one let's go to CNN for a second
they're obviously trying to change
strategy and to gain a different set of
viewers than they had during the Zucker
era I'm just wondering if that was the
right strategy going with Donald Trump
because it felt very 2016 and it felt
very repetitive to the 2016 Cadence and
you and I both know that 2024 in America
America is a vastly different place
demographically than it was in 2016. so
I questioned CNN's strategy there but
letting him be on the air I actually
like a lot of people are mad at me for
that I don't want Mr Trump to be
president again but I am a big believer
in free speech I Have Been a attacked
and pilloried by the Press so I think I
have standing to say this it's very very
important if you've got a guy like Trump
who's going to be in the mix in 2024 and
possibly president again it's very
important for the American people to
hear from and then I think it's up to
the media and people like myself and
others to explain the lie and see if we
can find candidates that can appeal to
his base and strip them away from Mr
Trump which you and I both know will be
very hard because he is a avatar for
their anger well he is and let's play
look let's be clear Donald Trump remains
very popular with his base there's no
question of that the poll numbers at the
moment show him streaks ahead of anybody
else in the race to be a republican
nominee and if it's a shootout between
him and Joe Biden to be president he's
got a very good chance according to all
the polls the problem a lot of people
have and I'm one of them and I've known
Donald Trump a long long time but
watching him last night I saw a guy
often in complete denial about reality
not least with his persistent claim that
he won the 2020 election without
producing any proper evidence to prove
this what did you make of it
yeah well I I when everyone talks about
Donald Trump lying I think you have to
take a step back and realize he believes
he won in 2020. he's not lying uh I mean
he obviously all the facts are against
that uh all of us who supported him at
one time or another have called on him
to denounce that lie and and admit that
he was defeated but he won't do it and
maybe he can't do it uh that's part now
of his presentation and I agree with
Anthony I think part of the problem uh
last night was that you had a very
partisan audience people were indeed
happy to see him they were cheering him
on Etc but honestly the reaction from
the liberal media in our country has
been so over the top they want him never
to be shown on television what are they
so afraid of do they really think that
most of the country tuning in last night
are going to be swayed that they're
going to become Trump voters if they're
so sure that everything he says is wrong
and
Blasphemous and abominable why are they
so afraid of him
I think that's a very good point I mean
I I you know I I believe in freedom of
speech as Anthony said I'm sure Jeremy
would Echo that you know that there is a
danger of someone like Trump if you push
him away into the Shadows it almost
empowers him like almost everything
negative would normally it has this
empowers somebody seems to work for him
I want to play a clip this is from when
I interviewed Donald Trump a year ago to
launch the show actually and it was a
perfectly cordial interview for a long
time until he got around to me telling
him what I thought of the 2020 election
claim
and here's what I was saying here I
believe it was a free and fair election
and that you lost you don't really
believe that's my belief well then
you're a fool however then you're a fan
maybe I am a fool maybe I'm the fool in
this conversation and you're a fool and
you haven't studied it
now Jeremy I watched Caitlin Collins
last night I felt her because
she is a very good correspondent I'm
becoming a good anchor but I've been in
that series when Trump will just turn on
you call you an idiot call you this call
you that it's hard for any journalist
actually you see you can't get into name
calling you can't say no I think you're
on it yes I think you're a liar yeah and
you've got a big crowd bang with him and
that's not why you're there because what
she did was she stuck to her guns and
because they had all these Trump fans in
the audience when they came up to ask
questions themselves they were very easy
stuff and she was there to try and put a
bit of Steel into the whole thing but
yeah it's very exposed but was it a
mistake for CNN to give him that time I
mean he is the front runner the
Republican nominee America is a
democracy if you believe in free speech
you've got to hear what people say even
if you don't like it that's the whole
thing and because it's a democracy in
the end the American people have a
choice right Anthony scaramucci can
Trump win a general election he can
clearly win the Republican nomination
the way they things are going but our
independence going to watch him trashing
a woman who's just won a five million
dollar lawsuit against him for sexually
abusing her are they going to watch that
and think I'm going to vote for in a
general election
well unfortunately peers a lot goes into
it you have to tell me what happens in
the last four weeks leading up to the
2024 election day because this stuff
gets decided last minute and so the
short answer is yes he can win I would
like to think that the mock demography
of the country has moved away from him
uh and I think it'll be impossible
certainly I can say this my friends on
the Democratic side uh and the Biden
people want to run against Trump they
have done the numbers and they think his
polling with Independence is absolutely
atrocious and just quickly he's got two
possibly three more indictments coming
right he's got the j6 indictment he's
got the Georgia indictment and the
document indictment uh that's death by a
thousand paper cuts for Independence so
I'd like to say no but I think the
answer is maybe right I mean this p is
it because all of this is completely
unprecedented no president's ever been
indicted no president's ever had a five
million dollar also over abusing a woman
being upheld by jury no one's facing all
these potential further indictments and
yet and yet Trump's poll numbers keep
going up amid this slew of Scandal does
it turn him into an almost unstoppable
train and is it in other words a
self-harming strategy really by the
Democrats to keep pushing all this stuff
against Trump
well no I don't think so and here's why
I think in 2020 Joe Biden very
successfully ran from his basement all
he did was run against Donald Trump
really and I think his strategy this
time round is to do the same thing he
can't hide because kovid gave him that
excuse he no longer has that excuse but
this time around he can just let Trump
make all the headlines and then the
headlines are going to be as you point
out presumably pretty negative they're
going to be a lot of indictments a lot
of Investigations meanwhile let's
consider what happened today today was a
horrible day for Joe Biden title 42 ends
tonight at midnight and there clearly is
no plan to stop the tens of thousands of
people that are massed at the southern
border about to come into our country we
have no plan forward on resolving the
debt ceiling problem but what are we all
talking about we're talking about Donald
Trump right and by the way also
representative Comer is launching all
these accusations about the Buy family
nefarious activities in Ukraine and
China and elsewhere so you know what I
think I think all this is working very
well for Joe Biden because we're all
talking about Donald Trump we're not
talking about Joe Biden you know what
you might be right but you could also
take your view it's working very well
for Donald Trump in a way it would not
work well for any other politician in
the history of planet Earth uh great to
talk to you Mr speaker thank you very
much Anthony always great to catch up
with you Jeremy you're staying because
I'm about to interview after the break a
Russian politician uh in Vladimir
Putin's party he's also a big TV star
for Russian State television he insists
Vladimir Putin is winning the war in
Ukraine and I'm going to have that
debate with him and then get Jeremy's
reaction to it it's after
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
sets out this five-point plan what has
it achieved so far nothing when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apologies
myself
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Facebook nonsense to
Jeremy Bowen is still with me Donald
Trump is notorious for his Whoppers we
just established but the Godfather
misinformation really resides in the
Kremlin speaking in a Bare Bones
military parade in Moscow this week's
totally to celebrate Victory featuring
one solitary tank Vladimir Putin accused
the west of unleashing War on Russia of
course the opposite is true and the war
that he began expecting victory over
Ukraine in just days has been a disaster
for his country Russia's military is
beset by infighting the head of Putin's
Wagner mercenary group is brazenly
questioning his dictator
what will the country do our children
grandchildren who are the future of
Russia and how can we win this war if by
chance and I'm just speculating here
it turns out that this grandfather is a
complete
extraordinary broadside there against
Vladimir Putin well today the UK
confirmed dissent long-range cruise
missiles to Ukraine As It prepares a
massive counter-offensive so is Putin
losing the war and his grip on power I'm
joined by evgeny pop-up and MP for
Putin's you know the Russia part in host
of the Russian 60 Minutes political news
program Mr thank you very much indeed
for joining me why is Russia losing this
war
let me correct you Pearson thank you for
giving me your flow I'm not a member of
any party in Russia I am in a faction of
uh parliamentary
um in Russian Duma of United Russia and
of course I'm in full bloody reporting
especially right now Russia is not
losing the war of course we can see you
plans to offense
to make an offense to our territory to
our troops to uh some um Russian cities
inside my country but we gonna fight for
our security grantees for Russian people
on donbass because uh you told a lot of
stories today but you didn't tell the
main story uh seven people have been
injured in hotlifka in donbass one
people was killed by Ukrainian bomb in
Donetsk today many people have been
injured in Hearthstone territory but you
only see and you only cover one side
hang on let me let me stop you there the
real story if you want the real story is
that Russia illegally invaded Ukraine a
democratic sovereign country which is
now a democracy illegally invaded it
over a year ago assumed it would just
run it over in a few days days met
extraordinary resistance from Ukrainian
people and have spent the next year in a
bit uh committing acts war crimes uh
acts of utter barbarism against the
Ukrainian people a deliberately
targeting civilians targeting maternity
hospitals shelling people in streets
committing mass murder all over Ukraine
that's that's the real story
that's real story for you because you
live in the myths of the appears because
I I thought you're a reporter and
journalist because we used to live in
New York at the same time and I uh well
remember you on CNN and you've been
great journalist great interviewer but
let me ask you let me answer your
questions if you're talking to me about
real situation but uh
uh I can tell you about real situation
um how about Georgia yesterday we
elicit ban on direct flights between
Georgia and Russia what was the United
States response they told bilisi the
real democratic government of uh
sovereign country that they can't fly to
Russia Georgians can fly to Russia we
canceled Visa Visa regime with Georgia
what uh the United States told us not
number one with respect with respect
you're not talking about what I just
explained to you is the real story why
did why did Russia illegally invade
Ukraine why is Russia committing endless
war crimes in Ukraine why is Russia
kidnapping tens of thousands of
Ukrainian children and taking them out
of the country
why are you why are you as a country
free doing all these things why is
Vladimir Putin behaving like a Brazen
dictator who thinks he can just seize
countries and kill anyone that gets in
his way that they're the questions I
want you to answer do you have any
answer question you want me to respond
first
why did you illegally invade Ukraine we
didn't wait Ukraine I can tell you a
long story don't bother with a long
story you did you clearly invaded
Ukraine Ukrainian government I can tell
you uh a lot of stories which I uh been
seen by my own eyes from donbass how
Ukrainian Army uh uh still killing many
Russians on dunbar's territory the
Ukrainian people the Ukrainian people
led by President zielinski are defending
themselves against what has resembled on
occasion genocidal Behavior by Russia
I went to Buca for example uh in Kiev
and saw for myself the scene of the
massacre that occurred there I talked to
people who had lost relatives in that
Massacre that was a war crime and
Vladimir Putin and others involved in
this are going to be held account to it
but I simply ask you again why did
Russia illegally invade Ukraine and now
that it's been going on for nearly a
year and a half and it was supposed to
last three days when are you going to
accept this has been a total Fiasco a
disaster for Russia we saw the pathetic
scene at the Victory Parade of one tank
which presumably is all you've got left
to show off on your Victory Parade when
are you going to Stop The Killing The
Killing and the murder you're like uh
Carlson this is your mono uh I'm just
telling you some cold hard facts
this is not a fact you don't know facts
because I I have heard your questions
because uh this story have began uh many
years before our Invasion to Ukraine
you mean
you should you should study history
yeah you're legally invaded Crimea in
2014 and then you were legally invaded
Ukraine last night I'm fairly up to
speed on the history of what you've been
doing
[Music]
seen ever seen everything by
you know and I can tell you about every
moment of this conflict from uh 2004
from yeah but you don't think you don't
think the Russia invaded Ukraine
therefore you're living in a totally
deluded World which doesn't exist
because obviously obviously Russia
invaded Ukraine everybody saw the whole
world saw it
but you call it a special preparation
I'm a special operation turned out to be
a complete disaster didn't it and now
you're losing and even the Wagner
mercenary group are calling Putin a
hmm
can I ask you yeah can I respond if you
can
of course I don't think it's funny Mr
Popoff
of thousands and thousands of innocent
civilians in Ukraine he's funny sorry I
don't that's the rashack can't say any
work I as Russian people as my state can
say a word and we can't explain what
happens because you live in the midst
you live in this Western stereotypes you
should respond uh
you should give
arrest warrants to toilet Lair to George
Bush for Iraq you should give well for
one day
okay hang on for what it's worth I led
the campaign in Britain with the Daily
Mirror newspaper against the Iraq War I
felt that well hang on let me finish I
thought that was an illegal invasion of
a sovereign country not dissimilar to
what we've been seeing in Ukraine from
Russia yeah and I'm not a I'm Not Afraid
Mr Popoff to admit that I think my
country behaved illegally with that
Invasion are you prepared to admit that
your country illegally
prime minister to uh
you didn't do that are you prepared to
admit your country illegally invaded
Ukraine
that's completely false uh and that's
not true okay
if you can't honestly if you're going to
deny the the obvious
then we're gonna have to leave it there
I appreciate you joining me thank you
very much indeed Jeremy
this level of delusion
where you can have a a Russian
politician who just will not even admit
they invaded a country when we all
watched it happen
what do we do with that well I think
from from their point of view what
they're after is the consistency of
their line they don't want leaks in the
front that they've put out and he's a
big supporter of Putin so he's echoing
what Putin says and he knows he can't
convince you
so I think that
when they talk like that they're talking
to their own audience but they're also
the fact is around the world
China India yeah the global South a lot
of people are more likely to agree with
him yeah I read somewhere I read
somewhere a third of the world has
sympathy with if not fulsome support for
what rush has done because they look at
what the West has done and you talked
about Iraq and they've thought and they
think well where's the difference I mean
that is a yeah but I I think that's held
I would say the difference is in this
country people like me on television uh
journalists were able to say freely if
we believe of that Invasion we have a
democracy and we have a free press and
over there it's an autocracy and it
comes out you know Putin sets the line
they follow it so I think all you can do
when you talk to these people is what
you do you've got to stick to your guns
and try and
um put the other case Donald Trump said
in in this uh CNN thing yesterday that
he thought he would solve the Ukraine
war in one day if he wins the wire let's
take a listen to this
put it a nice way
if I'm president I will have that War
settled in one day 24 hours
[Applause]
Preposterous maybe what he's saying is I
will turn off the tap that keeps the
ukrainians going of money and weapons
and then they'll lose that'll settle it
and that of course would be a great
victory for Putin if that if it happened
that way how do you see it ending this
Ukraine war well I think that this is
pretty important because if someone like
Trump does if Trump himself beats Biden
and goes into the the White House then I
think the money tap will get turned off
or really really throttled back and
actually the ukrainians really need this
Western support if they're going to win
Russia has a population four times
theirs so I think that if they don't
make breakthroughs this year then it's
going to be a long long conflict there's
a lot certainly as long as Putin's in
the Kremlin talking I can't let you go
without mentioning another long long
conflict the BBC's internal battle with
free speech and what you're all allowed
to say are not safe so the whole
garnetic thing he's a good friend of
mine full disclosure and I followed it
with great it's just you and I've talked
about this before yeah
um it's an interesting one it's
complicated I I've sort of come to
conclusion I'm interested in what you
think of my conclusion of this which is
that if you're news and current affairs
at the BBC you keep your gobshot about
your opinions if you are anything else
if you are Alan sugar if you're Gary
lineker even if you're David
Attenborough frankly anyone outside of
news current affairs
should just be allowed to tweet and say
what they like oh is that a mad idea I
think the flaw in the rules and clearly
they've accepted there is some kind of a
flaw because there's an inquiry and
assessment going on about it was that
whether or not it is possible or
desirable to apply full fat impartiality
to people like Gary should it be people
what he says about stuff
um I think it
I think it the more you talk about it
the more it matters I think that if you
just go on about it maybe it doesn't the
point is that was the rule I I work for
BBS in my whole life and I follow that
rule it's like stick of rock yeah it's
inside but you'll be you you have to be
in part yeah yeah of course I do because
I'm uh I'm the international for the BBC
I think that clearly there is something
to discuss when it comes to freelance
contribute contributors like Gary
lineker Alan sugar or whoever and what
they need to do and if this is what
they're doing is clarify things yes
Jeremy great to see you the podcast
series is brilliant it's I know it's
running on the radio this week and next
week but it's also available on BBC
sounds BBC sounds or wherever you get
your podcast how many parts there are
ten ten parts and how many am I in great
you're in at least a couple
Jeremy great to see you thank you very
much Steve for coming here one of the
great media figures of this country a
National Treasure have you been honored
yet or not uh I yeah I have had the I've
got the um
I got a medal from the Royal Scottish
Geographic
no nothing like that well that is
ridiculous if you're watching you can
sponsor me well if a new king is
watching and I think he probably is with
his Queen big fans of the show let's can
we correct this please
honor this great man I like the uniform
that Rory sure got to wear to the uh the
coronation
[Music]
great to see well I'm sensitive next
tonight the hospital for Canterbury is
attacked the government's migration
plans saying there is great damage to
the UK's reputation is he right should
he be saying any of this stuff if he's
the Archbishop of Canterbury we'll
debate that next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
sets out this five-point plan what has
it achieved so far nothing when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apologies
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh uncensored
the Archbishop of Canterbury delivered a
meticulous coronation service at
Westminster rugby on Saturday faultless
perfect this week he's been preaching
about politics instead just in World
musics and house laws claims the UK's
illegal immigration bill which includes
sending migrants to Rwanda is morally
unacceptable Rishi sunak has staked his
Premiership on stopping the boats more
than 5 000 people across the channel to
reach the UK this year so far so it's a
big problem
of course we cannot take everyone and
nor should we
but this bill has no sense at all of the
long-term and of the global nature of
the challenge that the world faces
it ignores the reality that migration
must be engaged with at source as well
as in the channel it is isolationist it
is morally unacceptable and politically
impractical to let the poorest countries
deal with the crisis alone and cut our
International Aid a little bit of a
different sound what he had in the Abbey
um so was it a fair intervention should
the Archbishop be saying this kind of
stuff about government policy and
Richard seism other observation would be
I didn't hear him come up with an
alternative plan in other words you can
say you're morally outraged by what the
government's doing but he hasn't really
offered an alternative and this is what
these people always do they say it's
unacceptable but they never have a
solution you see these people do you
mean let me tell you what's morally
unacceptable for an unelected Bishop
right to to try and defy the elected
will of the British people which is to
reduce both legal and illegal
immigrations
he is he is supposed to be our moral
guider as well as the Archbishop of
Canterbury in this country that is part
of his remit and he is in the house of
laws which may be enough I would like
okay abolish right but currently he is
yeah so isn't that part of his job no
but part of his job is to recognize the
difference between the the wishes of the
people when they're elected
representatives which for the last 13
years has been to reduce immigration and
to reduce illegal immigrations
all right this Rwanda thing it looks to
me like a complete Fiasco nothing's
happening nobody's gone to Rwanda it
turns out even if we start sending
people there it'll be tiny numbers
meanwhile the boats keep coming Richie
sooner said to me it's one of his five
big pledges I'll cut the votes but
nothing's working no you sound surprised
but I mean I said the minute they
unveiled the Rwanda plan that it would
be a fiasco but I tell you what I think
the Archbishop of canterbury's number
one job is and that is to look after his
congregation to protect the Church of
England as an institution to look after
his flock and to build it up and I've
just been looking at congregation
numbers since
and it directly tracks when he took over
so since 2013 when he came in
congregations have actually plummeted I
mean Fallen by something like a third in
recent years now part of that is to do
with pandemic but there I have a problem
with him too because I don't think he
provided any leadership moral or
otherwise during the Bible he
effectively abandoned us so Paula I
think the bigger picture here is should
he just keep out of this stuff I mean
he's got as is well right you said he
represents all the congregations of a
church swing of the country many of whom
will be conservatives and many will be
on the left is it really his place to be
politically divisive like this and take
a side of course it's his place to do so
and he was doing his job when he stood
up in the House of Lords but remember
because what do you think his job is
then well his job is of course to speak
up when he sees that things are
inappropriate when he sees things that
are morally wrong even in a specific
government policies it's a specific
government policy that impacts on
society both here and on the
international platform and that's what
he was referencing and remember this is
not just about the Archbishop this is
about lordana and this was about the 90
other members of the House of Lords who
wanted to stand up and have their voices
heard and can I just can I just say that
in terms of you know an unelected person
we've got Rishi sunak in power at the
moment he's an elected mp on a Manifesto
immigration and what we're talking about
when we talk about reducing immigration
we had 45 000 come across on the boat we
had 500 000 over 500 000 in terms of net
migration
why are we not talking about that well
we are
shortage occupation list has been
extended this year now we know why that
is it's because we need immigration
at the most vulnerable people
are options available
it recently transpired that about 35 of
these poor vulnerable people were young
Albanian economic migrants coming over
to try it on trying to enter illegally
and they were not from war-torn
countries all vulnerable they were young
healthy guys who wanted to come here and
and make money that's that that's not
the way you've categorized and that's
that's not all about people there's a
lot and let's first of all let's not
call them boat people
seeking Asylum whose Transportation
happens
there's two things that I want to say in
relation to that the first thing
obviously is that just because you can
point to one that doesn't mean that it
covers the rest if you tell me that
there's 35 if a third of all the people
there are two things
I've heard of all the people coming in
on the boat from Albania and they're
young men I have a problem with that the
second answer to your question but I do
want to fix what I'd proceed but I agree
and I do want this country I agree and I
think the Rwanda plan is nonsense and I
do want us to have a Humane Asylum and
Refugee program talk about Robert De
Niro for a minute how old were you when
you had your last child
in my mid-30s right I was 47 when I had
my daughter after three much older Lads
Robert De Niro 79 and he's just becoming
a father for the seventh time or
something
I'll be glad to get to 79 I won't be
looking to increase the population of
the Earth and ladies do you look at him
more admiringly for this for carrying on
in this way or is this ludicrous I think
it's extraordinarily casso used to bang
them out till his 80s I think he's he's
being extraordinarily selfish it's not
going to be it's about love and let me
tell you it's about many things but not
least about love it's about love peace
it's about I think if he actually looked
after that baby for very long it would
probably be the end of him at that age
so are we all agreed you think it's for
love dude
you said some Bonkers things on this
show that is probably the most Bonkers
uh thank you Pat good to see you all and
since of next tonight California
lawmakers consider reparations to Black
Californians compensation for decades of
State sanctioned discrimination is it
justice or is it just divisive we'll
debate that after the break
thank you
[Music]
foreign
sets out this five-point plan what has
it achieved so far nothing when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apologies
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
stay tuned I'm on the talk at nine
o'clock tonight and we're talking about
the government u-turn on the bonfire of
brexit laws Donald Trump loses it with a
TV presenter calling her nasty an aging
bull Robert De Niro becomes a dad again
at 79. that's all in about 10 minutes
[Music]
welcome back to blizzburger Central
California reparations task force this
week voted to approve recommendations on
how the state can compensate black
residents for historic discrimination
Governor Gavin Newsom has praise the
title Falls but appears to be cooling on
its advice perhaps because it could cost
1.2 million dollars per person this
debate is everywhere right now the
British Monarchy is faced repeated calls
for reparations for historic links to
the slave trade or BBC journalist Laura
trevelyn recently quit a job to campaign
for reparations having donated a hundred
thousand pounds herself to Grenada were
her family historically owned slave so
is this a form of historic Justice or is
it just divisive well I'm joined by a
member of the California reparations
task force Jovan Scott Lewis and Fox
News contributor and civil rights lawyer
Leo Terrell all right welcome to both of
you
um Joven um thank you let me ask you
about this because on the face of it
I've talked about this quite a lot
recently I don't understand how the pain
from historic sin
gets eased by banging a load of cash to
people now
almost all of whom will have not
suffered the original pain so explain to
me
sure thank you for having me so what
we're doing in California is we are
dealing with some of the more recent uh
experiences of discrimination beginning
with the period of Jim Crow here in the
state of California so what we call
these are really the lingering effects
of slavery
um and so we're not providing
reparations or recommending reparations
for slavery itself but for the ongoing
institutional and state-based harms that
the African-American Community has faced
but it's not only African Americans I
mean look slavery was an evil evil thing
nobody denies that but it's not just
African Americans who have suffered
historic sins and ills against them
where do you take the logic of this
argument does everybody does every
community in the world who has been
mistreated historically are they all
worthy of financial payment and if so
how is the world going to pay all this
stuff given we're already suffering a
global financial crisis
right that's a fair question so what
we're doing in California is we have
effectively calculated the economic
losses that the black community faced as
a result of State policies and so we're
effectively tracing you know the the
capital that this community lost over
the the past you know uh century and a
half of discriminatory you know State
policies and the argument is that we're
building a reparations proposal around
those direct losses in addition to that
we have you know dozens of policies and
programs that are helping to effectively
end the kind of discriminatory cycle
that African-Americans have faced in the
state who's going to pay the bill
but thankfully that's not the task
Force's job to figure out you know our
job was to create a methodology for
compensation for calculating those harms
and we're passing it along to the state
legislature I think the state has a
variety of options of how to pay for
this uh the state if it decides to pay
for it again we are recommending
compensation uh we have come up with
calculations for how compensations can
be arrived at but the state has a
variety of I think instruments and and
uh approaches to how to stretch out a
payment if they decide to do so all
right we bring in Leo Tara you'll be
waiting patiently your response to this
Leo
well you've done a great job of asking
the right questions first of all they
cannot prove any form of direct damage
at all I challenge him as a lawyer as a
civil rights lawyer Pierce here's the
situation they talk about
institutionalized racism where is it you
got black Mayors in this in this state
they talk about systemic racism where is
it where is the where's the white
Boogeyman that they're talking about
they cannot prove that people of color
black folks deserve 1.2 million dollars
does Kamala Harris need it does London
breed the mayor of San Francisco does
Karen bass who Barbara Lee who's a
congresswoman they can't show this
what's the real reason behind this peers
I'll tell you what it is in 2020 during
the summer of Rise you had a governor
named Gavin Newsom who wants to Pander
to Black Americans in California in
order to run for president and I will
submit to you that if such a bill was
even contemplated there would be a a
challenge to it because it violates
equal protection Clause is institutional
and it's racist and I would be the first
as a civil rights attorney to challenge
such a law last Point Gavin Newsom came
out a couple of days ago appears and
said he is not inclined to support
reparations in a cash payment all right
listen you've made some fiery points
back there so Joe Van I guess by my
overview has been about this issue are
we now in this country for example going
to seek some form of payment from
descendants of the Romans and the
Vikings for the marauding around Britain
uh and if not why not in other words
what's the difference really
ideologically behind what you're
striving to achieve for the
African-American Community for historic
issues and and that and me saying well
I'm sure some of my ancestors were
mistreated by Romans and Vikings I'd
like a large check please
sure and and that's a fair question and
you know counter to your other guests
claim we have established the exact
record of harm
um what we're talking about is that
African-American Community as recent as
1973 here where I live in South Berkeley
was demolished a commercial District was
demolished to build a train station
you're talking about African-American
communities that were demolished to
build Highway systems so the record of
harm is clear it is direct and I really
do welcome your other guests to view the
interim report that we released last
summer which is a 500 page detailed
report of the specific and direct harms
that African-Americans in the state have
faced at the hands of State policy and
that's what we're after yeah but I would
say this there are other communities the
gay community of the world right have
all had discrimination from the state
right you could argue and you could
argue that's caused a lot of pain and
harm so do members of the gay community
globally are they entitled to take your
you didn't say right we were
discriminated against by States we want
money for it in other words where do you
end
sure where you end is with State
responsibility and so if those other
communities and any communities can
establish an actual record of State harm
that is intentional and what I'm saying
is that these harms were intentional
we're talking about redlining where
black communities were directly targeted
by state dispossession we are talking
about an exact record that has been
established and so if any Community can
establish a similar record then I
encourage them to make a claim this is
what we're talking about okay this is
not about a cultural issue this is about
a record of harms that the state should
be responsible I understand and you've
expressed yourself in a very simple way
and I appreciate you for joining the
show and also to you Leo Terrell thank
you very much indeed to both of you well
that's it from me whatever you're up to
just keep it uncensored it's more fun
that way good night
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage stretching it you
can say whatever gender you are for your
sex your male or your female all right
JJ plus he becomes fabulous but Rishi
sooner and sets out this five-point plan
what has it achieved so far nothing when
we say believe women take them at their
word I'm sick of apologies
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
which will